what else here's a guy right here who
has a child with him it looks like let's
see what they're up to in the last
pocket has Brendon talked about how he
broke his thumb in a fight well I broke
my fourth and fifth metacarpal in a
fight had to get a plate on it so king
of sting it winning a fight but breaking
your hand becoming a cyborg getting that
titanium hitter uh-oh anyway Gang Gang
break bones I love it tell about that
Wolverine son welcome to the club yeah
that sounds like he did it on the
streets which was never encouraged yeah
yeah like he's freelance MMA do you have
you have any surgery you have to get
metal in no no one in here has it's some
serious [ __ ] when they do it when it
rains my [ __ ] hurts does it really never
gets cold it hurts worse like pins and
no way really rocks I thought that was
an old person thing nah
Wolverine makes it seem all cool and
[ __ ] but it ain't cool man
do you have a hard time going through
metal detectors no it never goes off in
that way huh I bet you could probably
roll dice a little better you know I'm
saying does it you've like have any
power in it any extra different vibe in
it mmm I wish Mary that movie was that
movie with the kid who broke his arm but
they could throw barrels yeah yeah
Rookie of the Year played for the
Chicago Cubs yeah who was in that movie
young Thomas he was a famous actor just
then he go to American Pie later Thomas
Ian Nicholas Gary Busey no time Jay busi
was the the other player on his TV not
busi almost did I almost got it put in a
movie with this guy Thomas Ian Nicholas
oh he's uh what was a movie mom remember
American Pie one two or three no no no
later than that dude it was like humble
pi7 dude it was sophomore slump it was
like a low it was not gonna be like a
super high budget movie do you want a
good fourth of July movie American Pie -
really yeah for the summer they go they
go on a little vacation they get summer
job
no it sounds horrible oh you're never
seeing the breaking pies uh-oh
all three fantastic American Wedding
I've got to watch a lot of stuff what's
it and walk the line I need to watching
it walk hard hard Dewey Cox I heard
that's good well the real walk card with
Joaquin Phoenix let's walk the line
that's the Johnny Cash biopic yeah or
bio pic or biopic um I agree
[Laughter]
[Music]